why is g3 being targeted specifically  again that's a tough question you never  know which way the federal government is  going to want to go there are other  collectives in the area I really think  it's a case of the government believing  that Aaron was commercializing and  profiteering off of it where it's a case  of three stores and 20,000 patients and  and they need to provide them safe  access to meds now you know any grower  of the collective shares his meds his or  her meds but to be able to provide  consistency and safety and you know  properly grown it was Aaron's intention  to be able to do all that and the  federal government sees it as  manufacturing and with the intent to  distribute so they're just slapping  straight-up drug charges